hi there steve kaufman here uh sunny day
here in vancouver i hope the my imovie
is going to last for the whole video
i'm going to talk about uh angelina
jolie but i have no videos no pictures
to show you i'm sorry um i'm going to do
this because i had mentioned on my
blog the linguist on language that
angelina jolie is learning russian for
her next movie and i said
kind of half and jess it's too bad that
she's not studying russian at link
whereupon serge came to my blog and made
the comment that um
you know judging by my russian like me
my russian pronunciation which is very
poor i can't remember his wording my
russian is poor
she could never learn at link she
probably has some kind of a
language coach which i'm sure is the
case
and ser said that he had one and spent x
number of hours and now he's taken for
an american or whatever
so what i'm going to do is talk a little
bit about language goals angelina jolie
and then i'm going to say a few words in
russian just to show you where i am at
in my russian
i think it's very important when we
study languages we all have goals anjani
angelina jolie is not going to be
reading
polstoy
she's not going to be getting involved
in political discussions which i like
doing i like listening to echo must be i
like the fact that i can understand what
they're saying i i like the fact that i
can read
uh i have few occasions to speak
uh perhaps you know since i've been at
it now over four years um
you know very rarely i go through
periods where maybe twice three times a
week i'll talk for 15 minutes or half an
hour with one of our tutors at link and
then i'll go for weeks without speaking
mostly i just listen and read and
increase my vocabulary using link
because that's my goal
angelina jolie's goal is to sound as
russian as she can
saying lines that you may not even
understand and that's fine that's a very
practical goal
is sergio's goal for whatever reason was
to
sound like an american
for whatever reason
i have said before i don't think trying
to sound like a native is a very
meaningful goal i don't expect this to
be mistaken for a native in any of the
languages that i speak and most of them
i speak a lot better than i speak
russian
uh
so we have to look at one's goals i
think that in
for me the main goal in language
learning is always comprehension i
always want to understand what people
are saying i want to understand well
enough to read and i'm quite content to
let my speaking skills come along which
they inevitably do
i am very much looking forward to
watching angelina jolie speak russian
i'm happy to watch her no matter what
she's speaking
now
i'm gonna try to speak in russian i've
been working recently on my korean and
my portuguese because i'm going to
portugal in the fall and i've also taken
up the korean challenge because we have
korean now at link
so the russian's a bit rusty but
yanimagu
a
foreign